hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about how to apply your one word
so I recent was interviewed by a
podcaster named Jay Wang we did it on my
channel he took the other for his
podcast super interesting guy and found
out that he was in Toronto so we got
together and we did a number of videos
if you guys watch the ants press shows
from last week you'll have seen Jay a
number of times has a lot of amazing
wisdom and valuable knowledge to share
and in our conversation we're talking
about what is his one word what is he
staying for how does he applied to his
business because when you look at his
website in his podcast and you know his
emails and everything that he's putting
out there the message seems to be all
over the place and that's everybody by
the way write a lot of your messages you
guys watching your messages are
inconsistent are all over the place
don't have a lot of focused meaning on
it and so he came back after talking
with me at the studio and he recorded
this message to me that I thought would
be interesting to share with you I got
his permission and then I'm gonna answer
his question at the end for everybody
hey Evan Jay here just wanted to make
you this recording to tell you a quick
story of me discovering my one word I
thought this would be a little more
efficient in terms of you just reading a
long-winded email by me so here it goes
I was on the TBC coming back from your
dance studio had a great time by the way
and I was really just reflecting on you
know our last conversation and you kind
of pushing me to really think about why
I was doing what I was doing and why I
started even down this path like why do
I have a podcast why do I have all these
things and and figuring out what my one
word would be and I was thinking and
looking back at all the kind of big
decisions in my life you know whether it
was quitting my job or you know starting
a podcast and doing the work that I'm
doing now and and I realized a
commonality between all of them is that
this belief that I just wanted to prove
to myself and or to other people that it
was possible that it was possible to you
know to create a business without any
funding in the beginning it's possible
to you know you know
interview some amazing amazing people
and to be able to learn from them and
apply them my own business and it's
gonna improve my life and it's gonna
improve other people's lives it's
possible to create a community around
the idea of people that are choosing
legacy over currency so and in looking
back at all the amazing interviews and
people that and you probably know this
to people that you've studied they've
all done something in that capacity
where they went from impossible to
possible so I guess all this is to say
that my one word is the word possible
and yeah it was really kind of epic kind
of like a weight lifted off my shoulder
a little bit in terms of coming to that
level of clarity one question I did have
for you though now that I feel confident
in my like one word in being possible do
I start going all in on that right like
do I just change everything on every
profile and every you know social media
thing to you know hashtag possible or
you know kind of transition over to that
right away or do I just start letting it
seep in to a lot of the work you know
whether it's just signing off in a
certain way or having it included in
some of the work and then that kind of
acts as a pre validation for it or do
you just go all in so let me know your
thoughts either way
hope you're having I don't know what
Friday is for you I'm assuming it's not
video day or interview day um so I hope
you're having a about Friday and hope to
chat with you soon thank you so much so
one I'm so happy for you I'm so pumped
for you Jay because finding finding your
one word is such an amazing eye opening
experience that then you can start to
think of well okay if possible that's
your word then what can I do to go more
in an R word what test can I run to see
you know what possible means to me and
the reaction I get from my audience and
also what areas of your life and
business don't live up yet don't you
know don't embrace possible for you and
those are areas of deficiency that you
can build up and start to see amazing
growth in and so I would recommend a
couple things for you
now you
one word I think it apply to everybody
was going through this process too now I
highlight a lot of this a lot obviously
in my book as well this is a high-level
overview for you to to test out first I
would work on developing my credo and
what the credo is is figuring out three
things that break up what possible means
to you there's a common definition of
possible that most people would think of
when you say it's possible what is
possible meaning to you what does
hashtag possible mean that's the
difference between just the word
possible and hashtag possible that Jay
Wong is branding around what does it
mean so how does it break down pick
three things that break down possible
for you so maybe something in there is
about being a change maker maybe there's
something there about belief maybe
there's something there about being a
rebel and there may be other things in
there that you know that most people
wouldn't think of but that make up
possible for you so as an example for me
believe most people think
self-confidence believe in yourself
hundred percent that's one of them the
the other one is believe in what you're
doing so have passion for you for the
work that you're doing right believe in
the work that you're creating you're
making podcasts believe in the podcast
not just the end result the process have
to be important and then three is
believe that it's going to work out even
though you know you only see darkness
around you there it's gonna work out
there will be that light you will make
it have the conviction to follow through
so believe hashtag believe for me breaks
down into passion self confidence and
conviction and all of the stuff that I
create falls into those buckets whether
it's articulated that way or not that's
always the guiding vision behind it and
so I would encourage you that now that
you did that first step do the next step
in figuring out how does your credo
break down what are the three most
important things that that make up
possible for you and then turn those
into sentences
you know if it's rebel okay what is like
be a rebel and then give me a sentence
about what that is it's a command it's a
command for yourself to live by everyday
in the command for your followers to
follow this order because it's important
because it's gonna change your life so
that's the next step and that will help
give you extra clarity you mentioned
that finding possible give you clarity
this will add that extra layer of
clarity that then you can make all
future decisions through in terms of
applying it next
I'm not a big believer in going all-in
on it until I've proven that it works
and that's maybe me maybe I'm maybe I'm
risk-averse maybe that's just my style
no some people love to burn the boats
and burn the bridges and just do it and
that's the only way they're ever gonna
succeed and so that may be your option
what worked for me was once I found
believe I thought it was crazy I thought
it was too big I thought it was you know
Who am I to to come up with a word like
believe a lot of people have used it
before all of these kind of self doubts
I decided I'm gonna try something small
because the risk is especially for
someone like you who you've already set
up you've already established sure you
could you know you want to grow you want
to be bigger you want to do more but
you've already done stuff up to now up
to this point it's not starting from
scratch and a rebrand can be a big and
painful thing you want to make sure it's
the right thing to do so the first thing
I tested was just a newsletter I did a
newsletter around believe instead of my
normal newsletter and I got a 50%
increase in engagement from that
newsletter my sister wrote back to me
she was one of the first write back to
me and say that I actually read your
newsletters now so who those off to a
good start then the next thing I did was
to make the video and I've told this
story a number of times but I made a
video around believe in my previous best
video out of hundreds of videos on the
channel my best video had a hundred
thousand views in one year which was
good and I was super pumped I guess my
best video I crossed a hundred thousand
views this is amazing
I did a believ video and it hit a
hundred thousand views in one month
which is crazy and now is over a million
views and bumping up against two million
soon enough that uses the only metric
but everything that I was around believe
automatically did way better than my
normal stuff my older stuff and so that
started give me the confidence to go
more all in on it right I had some early
signs that worked out and that made me
want to do it more and more and more so
I rebranded my website you know my
social media my youtube channel to the
point now where people associate me with
belief right people see believe on a
sign somewhere and they said they'd
shoot me a Twitter picture or an
Instagram picture with believe and say
I'm thinking of you and just reinforces
the message where the same thing can
happen around possible and it also it
also cements that it's the right word
for you that extra validation that extra
stating that extra going through the
process the more you do it your one word
should feel more either more like it's
you like this is if I'm a hundred
percent or more awkward like uh you know
I don't know that this is actually me
and so I don't want you to do all this
rebranding and do a lot of work and then
have to do it again because it was the
wrong move so that's how I would start
when I think about possible I think of
Les Brown he would always end his shows
with it's possible a lot of his a lot of
his segments were around it's possible
you know you've been in person
development I'm sure you know who les is
this is probably a lot you can learn
from him he's still creating some
content but you know most of it was was
older stuff so that's a starting point
that's the starting point I would try to
find the easiest smallest test to get
started to prove to yourself that this
works
like I hate wasting time I hate doing
work that's not working I want to test
it see if it works if it works great
keep going if not move on something else
and so I would find whatever the
smallest easiest test is for you and
then apply to that because this will
have a ripple effect through everything
that you do eventually right if you're
looking at hiring somebody right you're
gonna hire someone to do your graphic
design to record your podcast to promote
your podcast to make your website
whatever you're gonna build a team to
build this thing up you want somebody
who who believes impossible as well who
loves possible who wants to help do more
possible for you right do it better than
you do make websites and all that stuff
so that can be used to attract the team
to you it can be used to attract media
and get your message out it can be used
for your audience to easily share your
message for you it can be used to
attract capital to figure out your R&D
process to figure out the next product
and services that you're gonna create
and sell right so in the book I go
through core campaign company core is
the is the easiest lowest hanging fruit
it's this process that you just went
through or going through it's finding
your one word finding your credo and
then what that means to you as a human
being
campaign now gets into most people think
market is an easy way to start right so
campaign is let's create a campaign
around your one word let's create
campaign around possible
what's a small test what's a newsletter
what's a video what's one show on your
podcast what
ending off the podcasting guys remember
it's possible what sound effect on your
show is possible right for me he's here
the believe airplane right it used to be
this crop duster this thing flying
across the screen the crops sound like a
crop duster it's like that's not believe
I wanted to have this sonic jet taking
off and then breaks the sound barrier
with this boom at the end right that's
why you see at the end of my videos the
plane taking off and you hear the boom
what's the logo mine's a paper airplane
because we're taking off we're leaving
the safe ground of what we know and off
doing something risky and dangerous and
it's a paper airplane because
entrepreneurs were we're you know we're
fighting the wind we're you know we're
we're not we don't have the resources to
go out and buy a jet right we're
starting with what we have and we're
going against the odds that we want our
thing to soar and take off so all of
this matters right possible ties into
your logo ties into your sound it ties
into your branding they'll tie into all
of this stuff that's campaign and then
company is building a company around it
building a team building a culture
raising capital finding mentors all of
the stuff that you need to build a
successful company should still be seen
through the lens of possible so the book
will help guide you through all that but
just as your first step we're opening up
a wide world of amazing possibilities
for you Jay and everybody watching to
figure out your credo and then figure
out the smallest test because this has
to be practical this isn't just some
frou-frou lalala and feel good about
myself right it has to work for you if
it doesn't work for you then there's
something wrong right like the concept
wasn't executed well you know and I
don't want you spending time doing
something that's not getting results so
prove to yourself that it works I'm
excited I'm so excited I'm excited for
you I'm excited for other people going
through the process I'm excited for all
the entrepreneurs that this is going to
help so Jay thank you for for allowing
me to give some extra clarity on that
thank you for the question thank you for
your your openness and awesomeness and
report back let me know let me know what
you end up having in your credo and let
me know what your first test is going to
be
how are you gonna start to apply and see
if you feel a measured difference or not
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope this video added some extra clarity
for you guys too if you have a question
for me
leave it in the comments below and maybe
I'll make a video reply for that one as
well I just want to give a quick shout
out to Amanda Jane LaBelle from rest of
wild Cote UK Amanda thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book really
really really means a lot to me one last
thank you for all you guys watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon